as data science and technology continue
to advance we're seeing more and more
industries investigate how their data
can make an impact
when it comes to healthcare data is now
at the very heart of solutions that help
improve patient outcomes and allow
scientists to develop new therapies
in today's video we're going to walk you
through an example of how you might
build a data platform for advancing
clinical trials
using looker and other google cloud
services
and while we'll be focusing on life
sciences research for today's
demonstration
it's important to note that these
technologies can be leveraged for a
variety of use cases throughout the
healthcare industry and beyond
[Music]
in 2020 as many as 5.8 million americans
were living with alzheimer's disease
and this number is projected to nearly
triple to 14 million people by 2060.
so today we're focusing on building a
data-powered application to help
physicians and researchers analyze huge
amounts of information to discover new
alzheimer's treatments
let's dive in
when it comes to working with healthcare
data privacy and data protection are at
the very forefront of your technology
considerations
lucky for you google cloud is committed
to keeping your patient data safe with
services that meet fundamental security
and privacy requirements for protected
health information
now that we have housekeeping out of the
way let's get back to the fundamental
problem
when it comes to analyzing new
treatments there are loads of different
data sources we need to consider
mris and pet scans
patient medical history data
positive and negative side effects
reported from drug treatments
and lab data collected over time
and we're not just talking about small
volumes here
medical imaging alone generates about
two trillion images per year
or nearly four and a half exabytes of
data
okay so we have lots of data in all
different structures
how do we make sense of all of this and
give practitioners the insights they
need
let's start by taking a closer look at
looker
lookers architecture is unique among
business intelligence platforms
because it's powered by looker's
modeling layer look ml which sits
directly on top of your data warehouse
looker is an api first application which
provides data as a service to other
systems by leveraging look ml
looker's modeling layer
to deliver consistent data across all
applications
in the application we're building today
bigquery and looker are the primary
analytical engines for structured
patient data
but we'll also use cloud storage to
serve up unstructured data like images
and vision ai and tensorflow to add
additional insights into our bigquery
data
now the question is how will this
architecture empower healthcare
professionals and life sciences
researchers let's find out
okay so let's pretend you're a health
care provider who has patients
participating in a clinical trial you
can navigate to the application landing
page to see a high level overview of the
trial including information like the
research question the trial status when
it started and the type of study
additionally you can dig into some of
the details for each treatment group
like seeing the severity level and a
breakdown of all the participants
now aside from simply viewing high level
statistics you can interact with this
data by adjusting the timeline
maybe to better understand if the usage
of each treatment has changed throughout
the trial
now the super cool part of all this is
that we're using third-party ui
components for custom experience
but we're still pulling data from our
unified data model ensuring data
governance and consistency
okay so you have a sense of the overall
trial now let's move over to my patients
the first four tabs over here allow you
to see detailed information about
patients
ranging from the basic information like
their sex
age blood type and bmi
to more complex information like medical
events and family history
but that's not all like we showed before
interaction is key here
so you can drill into things like the
hippocampal volume to get more details
on what's going on here
now you can see emoto pulling in data
through looker's embedded iframe which
we'll talk through more in just a minute
back on my screen i can navigate to the
predictive insights tab
and here we'll be able to see the
results of our artificial intelligence
solution where we can see things like a
description of the recommended treatment
and predicted positive and negative side
effects
it's important to note that google cloud
toolset allows us to feed in
non-quantitative data like mri images
into a statistical model
for example using vision ai we can
identify and measure the size of certain
neural structures
these insights help guide physicians and
ease the burden of searching for
microscopic structures in the brain so
they can focus on treating and managing
their patients health
now that you know your treatment plan
you can share details with the patient
or send them directly to the pharmacy to
be filled
so all this data in the demo is stored
in bigquery but can be abstracted
further using looker and fed into other
microservices across google and beyond
like the 3d brain studio over here
which uses our technology to take
patient 2d images and present it in 3d
for physicians
although custom and hybrid solutions
create an amazing experience for end
users they can sometimes take more
effort to build
often times there's a need to
incorporate standard embedded reports
because it enables organizations to
quickly integrate dashboards into
applications
let's take a closer look
like we showed before in our drill modal
looker dashboards can be fully embedded
through an iframe to show the fastest
time to value and allow developers to
focus on more custom feature sets
if we go back to our main application we
can also navigate to the trial data page
here we'll be able to see more detailed
overview of all trial data with full
access to looker's built-in capabilities
like scheduling and download
functionality drilling and alerts
awesome so now you've seen how to use
google cloud to create a tailored custom
data experience
by combining intelligent and secure
google cloud services you can build
amazing applications that leverage
artificial intelligence and data
analytics to design build and scale the
next generation of modern data
applications
ready to learn more check out the links
below
you